alors justement on va ouvrir avec un
sujet qui a fait qu'ils vous chaussez
vous à un gros gros sujets là gros
sujets non mais celui ci a révolté vous
a révolté les heures et les autres et je
pense que les téléspectateurs vont avoir
envie de réagir puisque c'est une
internaute impuissante qui a partagé ce
week-end sur les réseaux sociaux une
vidéo absolument de la sente des
hurlements de sa voisine victimes de
violences conjugales vraiment une vidéo
choc
[Musique]
la vidéo a été tournée par dont la nuit
l'auteur de la vidéo une voisine a
pourtant appelé la police ils ont fait
un contrôle d'identité
et puis ils sont repartis s'invite après
les cris ont recommencé les cours ont
commencé plus belle du coup j'ai pris
mon téléphone j'ai filmé et j'ai twitté
en quelques heures
la vidéo est vu plus de 270 mille fois
de son côté police secours assure avoir
respecté la procédure
la dame qui était à son domicile elle a
été contactée à quatre reprises et il ya
toujours manifestés dont son refus de
déposer plainte et qu'elle ne souhaitait
pas l'intervention de la police
depuis les voisins ont décidé d'écrire
au procureur pour apporter leur
témoignage
en france une femme meurt tous les trois
jours sous les coups de son conjoint
vraiment c'est une vidéo glaçante à moi
je ne sais pas comment vous vous l'avez
reçu mais moi j'ai reçu ça comme un coup
de poing vraiment tous les trois jours
en france ya une femme qui meurt sous
les coups de son conjoint ou ex conjoint
seuls 19% des victimes porterait plainte
par peur des représailles
on se trouve peut-être la même dans un
cas de figure comme celui ci puisque la
police se rend au domicile de cette
jeune femme qui refuse de porter plainte
mais avec son son tortionnaire à côté
d'eux peut-être là le problème la
question
la police s'en va et les cours
reprennent puisque à nouveau les voisins
film et on n'entend que ça reprend
malheureusement quelle est votre
réaction
caroline il ya plein de trucs à dire
dans les choses police dans les choses
positives
il a les réseaux sociaux quand ça sert à
ça voyez mon dieu mon dieu heureusement
que ça existe bravo la voisine drapeau à
l'avoir essayé de l a eue à elle a eu un
acte très courageux parce qu'on imagine
que voilà c'est pas juste une simple
engueulades et elle est très très loin
donc elle a quand même eu le courage de
témoigner a découvert il faut quand même
vraiment la plus agents qu'elle va je
peux maintenant le mari en question
connaissait de la grenelle rage cette
voisine
voilà vous êtes tout moment elle a fait
ça très
de manière très claire et après moi je
dis il ya la loi et puis à la réalité
et franchement on devrait pouvoir passer
outre la procédure la loi on s'en fout
dans ces cas là je veux dire dit que les
pleins de pas porter plainte d'un
policier et non assistance à personne en
danger de la part de la police qui vient
qui se déplacent qui constate et qui
repart c'est inadmissible on ne devrait
pas être tolérée en france alors qu'en
pauliste d'humour dit on a appelé quatre
fois cette dame qui quatre fois refuse
notre notre notre assistance donc on est
dans notre entre guillemets dans la
limite de ce qu'on peut faire
vous vous dites non c'est pas vrai c'est
pas dans la limite de ce qu'ils peuvent
faire ils doivent contre pas c'est
exactement ça l'aloe je veux défendre
absolument la police qui est là on est
là dans sur ce plateau se rend pas
compte de leur quotidien des appels
comme ça ils ont donc très souvent
donc chaque cas est particulier que
peuvent-ils faire de mieux
enfin façon de parler moi je comprends
ce que vous êtes en train de me dire
bien série je comprends simplement ou si
cette dame
heureusement visiblement elle est encore
en vie mais si cette dame et avait
succombé sous les coups de son compagnon
alors qu'ils n'en sont pas revenus doit
attendre
qu'est ce que la transe canaux en effet
que les policiers soient aidés en
durcissant la loi pour que cet homme
soit beaucoup appréhendent épargnés
c'est ça mais le oui que peuvent-ils se
faire de plus il faudrait que elle aussi
est la possibilité de vouloir encore
plus se sauver et et les c'est peut-être
bas les policiers à agir au lieu de à
chaque fois au fait ça s'appelle ça
s'appelle ça s'appelle faire une enquête
simplement exempt ça veut dire elle a
appelé quatre fois on fait une enquête
où on dit cette viande par ailleurs
travailleurs sociaux face à ces
premières choses et la deuxième chose
combien de fois ça arrive dans les
commissariats où on vient déposer une
main courante pour ce type de chose ou
pour autant jeu heroes vous dis bombe a
coûté réfléchissez bien ou alors amenez
moi la victime ou etc
non il ya un moment quand il a
parfaitement raison c'est non assistance
à personne en danger et en plus là je
trouve que c'est vraiment une espèce de
relâchement mais alors c'est que c'est
pas normal du tout c'est de la faute de
la police tout simplement ben ce qu'à la
fin de la police mais elle peut
intervenir enfin ça c'était toi toi tu
serais pas intervenu bon peut-être que
toi tu serais pas intervenus parce que
tu as la trouille mais normalement tu
interviens quand même et bayer justement
y ait des voisins alors sont ils
intervenus scc la filiale a enregistré
les tweets et 260 mille fois et elle
peut pas faire mieux et après ils
réagissent justement parce qu'elle a
tweeté arrête ces hypocrites tout ça
elle est divine bien elle explique
deviendront le reportage de surcroît
sofia la voisine que cinq minutes
seulement après le départ de policiers
il pouvait pas attendre d'eux
dans la cage d'escalier en extrapolant
avec des si évidemment on refait paris
mais moi je comprends pas je suis
totalement d'accord avec caroline il ya
les droits les droits en tant que
citoyens puis les devoirs et ça c'est un
devoir que que sofia estimé notamment
que ma les forces de l'ordre n'a pas
voulu porter plainte
la police aurait dû entre guillemets les
blancs barrés de forces au sol du mans
et en patientant cinq minutes plus tard
il se sera aperçu directement de la
violence de ce qui se passait dans cet
appartement et c'est juste inadmissible
alors je rappelle que parce que c'est
quand même bon de rappeler la loi
l'auteur de les auteurs de telles
violences le violences conjugales
encourt jusqu'à trois ans de prison pour
violences psychologiques et de 3 à 10
ans ainsi que jusqu'à 150 mille euros
d'amendé pour violences physiques
évidemment bravo à cette dame cette
jeune femme l'avoir alerté en cas
d'avoir essaie de faire quelque chose
c'est vrai qu'on sent impuissant dans
ces cas là elle a appelé la cour à la
file mais voilà elle a fait le maximum